questo è il mio primo figlio ufficiale
nel nuovo studio la mia nuova location
ma che vi sembrerà strano sembra strano
che a me e ho girato questo video un po
tardi e quindi o con dovuto aggiungere
le due luci ma normalmente insomma non
sarà così buio dietro diciamo perché
avrò produce dalla finestra super con
trenta tra l'altro novità nei dvd video
si saranno due inquadrature tra poco
vedrete come funziona questo nuovo video
abbiamo fare sul nuovo sme senza colla
che visto su instagram sta spopolando
questo tipo di slam è scoperto come
fanno senza colla grazie al video su
youtube e di una ragazza
uno sbaglio poi vi lascero il link nella
descrizione comunque è in mostra in una
dispensa colla supersic lì che sembra
quasi acqua quando lo tocchi sono super
curiosa di farlo con voi di provarlo
spero che si va bene lo scopriremo a
schermo e ovviamente come sempre andiamo
parlasse kennedy di rock ingredienti
dove che sarebbe un telefono perso per
stordirli sembra che fanno a mettere le
mani nella forma infatti climatico e
volete sapere com'è fatto il mio studio
iscrivetevi attivate le notifiche perché
sto pubblicando in questi giorni dei
video blog così appunto vi farò vedere
com'è fatta la stampa come la sto
arrivando
il tutto quindi mi affondo di fate le
pacifiche per esser lì prima di vincere
che volevo dire velocissimamente di un
servizio fantastico che ho scoperto che
mi hanno avuto contattato si chiamavano
giusta tutto e prima di trasferirmi
andiamo al punto il messaggio chiedendo
cosa mi riserva tutto vi faccio vedere
qua lo screenshot e guardate la loro
risposta incredibile incredibile ma vero
finissimo stessa a fare qualcosa del
vostro futuro potete chiedere quello che
penso ma qualcosa che succederà la
nostra abilità so se qualcuno che che
innamorato di questo momento
facebook pro calcio segreto ricambierà
quello che volete
basta inviare un sms al 48 70 870
vivendo il vostro nome cognome e città e
pur potete appunto scrivere la domanda
che con le sue storie a budva tutte
perché anche il viaggio si perché a un
privato le risposte che avete ricevuto
che lo so che se volete potete mandarmi
le vostre risposte su instagram in diver
e vedi un po cosa predisse del vostro
futuro milano con qualche il link del
sito descrizione se potete vedere essere
informazione più cose insomma ok allora
semplicissimo
solo due ingredienti 3 pochissimi
comunque il presente è semplicemente io
l'ho rifiutata dal rubinetto
e allora lei nel video nella un bel poi
vediamo allora vediamo prima tutta la
sottigliezza
se avete qualche consiglio su come
arredare uno studio ad esempio qua
dietro 4 stata mentre sostituto voi
qualche idea fatemelo sapere nei
commenti
e se volete vedere altri senza collo
ovviamente lasciato un bel laica 10.000
l'ice una nuova ricetta di planned senza
colla allora tutti aggiungerne ancora
lascia ok aggiungo la terza bottiglietta
d'acqua sostituto per tutto ok direi che
così s melograno besa trapunta grande
party se come ingrediente magico e
questo e clicchiamo worldcom other
allora poi di cerco su internet su
amazon lo cerco suo modo in italia e mi
metto il link in descrizione io l'ho
comprata su amazon è perché sono spagna
quindi su quel momento si sarà molto in
italia comunque melo certo mi metto il
link in descritto rea la ragazza di un
vizio d'enza a 5 cucchiai nigma aveva
meno acqua quindi non è lo zero vediamo
allora poi metti un po vediamo se cambia
notato un sospetto quindi ne sto
mettendo un cucchiaio intero per
iniziare
dentro me cucchiaio insomma un cucchiaio
questo questo cucchiaio
siamo sui tre proviamo con 3 cucchiai
vediamo sensi già a cambiar consistenza
altrimenti ne aggiungo altri oggi
strettissimo mischiato bene il collare
un po brutto che poi è il colore e un
altro in questa cosa dio è un lentissimo
stragi non diventi uno tale impegno e
questo perché è alquanto brutti ha detto
entrambi comunque poi non vi preoccupate
perché poi andiamo a matri coloranti
sembrate un po trasformando quello che
super celati noto comunque dopo bisogna
togliere i grumi perché vedete che sono
formati di grumi super grossi e
bisognerebbe andare un colino solo che
io non ci sono il cartellino quindi
ritorni erano tutti manualmente in forma
sarà un processo super di allora ho
trovato un'altra soluzione
trovare questa soluzione e cioè
ammontari questo alta comunque dovrebbe
essere guardiamo naturale notte si che
si usa anche per preparare dei piatti
quindi non vi preoccupate non è non
dovrebbe essere tossico no non è che
deriva dalle carte e ha così tolgoi
krumins volete voi potete toglierli non
lo so io ci sono giusto ieri con questi
manualmente ma questi su entroterra
quindi niente riva dosso dire così
vediamo se funziona da vedere ma il
risultato dovrebbe essere fantastico
che strano se ti il bimbo
ok ora questa scelta sono rimasti un po
di grooming dette è in realtà
bisognerebbe insomma toglierli appunto
con il colino riesce a toglierli tutti
ma va bene
vediamo dunque come ne esce così vado
ammette il colorante utilizzare luogo
perché vediamo queste verde più non va
messo troppo colorante se volete che
rimanga un po trasparenti
io un inizio mettendo nei quattro borse
andiamo a mischiano vediamo un po non la
colorata
ancora un po ha attivato contestare la
firma tore che volete
la timpanelli utilizzava come questa
mattina quindi immagino che abbia un
tocco la vorace io voglio stare
la soluzione per lei e indycar
nanosensori non mi veniva più difficile
in italiano
allora sinceramente non capisco perché
debba essere attivato non essendo poi
fare può essere la relazione non lo so
anch'io dello spam
un bel po di più gli stream cerca bene
comunque non so quale possa essere la
reazione perché deve essere ogni tanto
magari non deve essere per forza
attivato volessero provate fateci sapere
nei commenti se ha funzionato anche
senza attivatore vado a me troppo di
bicarbonato inizio il mescolamento che
non ci credevo ma dopo un po di
mescolamento si sta solidificando sarò
diventato
ad esempio fatto perché dopo che i
nostri latte per un personaggio c'è un
bel po ora dovete lasciarlo riposare per
un'ora le dice però penso che queste
furono state più diventa trasparente
quindi io provo a lasciarlo un'ora e
vediamo come diventa complici
ecco qua sta solidificando incredibile
ed è molto traccia molto difficili però
animarsi vede proposta ad aggiungere un
po di strutture i denti perché ancora è
un po tifoso
mettiamo è solo perché famiglia reazione
cosa trasparente staccando così il limit
line trasparente in un solo mese è
possibile che sembrava però con sembra
fatto con la colla e un sacco di acqua
perché no vabbè è assurdo ed affari è
diventato un super super ciclismo sembra
acqua sempre di impartire le mani
nell'acqua però poi si tocca
frighi tv non ho veramente malissimo con
se stesso del genere in uno slam e secco
sembra fatta e ora non è finita qua
perché affettiamo un'ora perché dovrebbe
appunto schiarire del tutto è vero che
come del gruppo lo dovete provare a
farlo è fantastico guardate sempre di
immergere le mani nell'acqua e presi
stadio fantastico
ok ora aspettiamo un ora in ora volte
mirato che il t9 troppo figo lo voglio
fare in tutti i colori
veniamo tra un'ora come diventa
incredibile non si sa niente razzi
allora ho fatto passare più di un'ora
sono passate tipo 3 4 ore perché ancora
non è diventato completamente
trasparente vedete è un po o parco
quindi penso che ci voglia un po più di
tempo per volevo assolutamente farvelo
vedere subito perché è fantastico è
sembrato vero di toccare l'acqua e fa
dei suoni a smr bellissimi quindi ora ve
lo faccio vedere
non so se sono io che ho messo magari
troppo colorante però guardate conte
glock si ma la sensazione di con
infilate le mani dentro è bellissimo
sentite che rumori
è super morbido ed è super rilassante
perché sembra immergere le mani
nell'acqua quella tecnico è bellissimo
qui a meri la sansa coi suoni acquatici
fatemi sapere se anche voi vi rilassano
karate e gigante ed è fighissimo
[Applauso]
sentite per morire o sembrato per di
toccare l'acqua e sto pensando di farne
un altro rosa in cui magari ma con meno
colorante così penso che diventi più
trasparente questo comunque lo lascerò
lo lascerò riposare ancora per un po
così per essere diventa completamente
trasparente ma è fantastico cioè portate
si stacca completamente dalla ciotola e
fa questo rumore di acque fighissimo è
davvero come di sly mai più strani che
abbia mai fatto ma anche più belli di
slant senza cosa
e tra fermate di suoni finta sì sì
quindi io l'ho fatto riposare un 3 4 ore
e questa è la consistenza corte com
cicli e assurdo sembra l'acqua sembra
non lo re soprattutto vorrei provolo
toccare perché è fantastico fa sapere
nei commenti se volete che faccia altri
colori io pensavo rosa scrivetemi nei
commenti e colori volete che faccia o se
volete che provi a fare tipo una corsa
arcobaleno o se volete che faccia tipo
una piscina fatto concreto sm bimbe
ricade addosso tutto quello che volete
mi raccomando lasciate un bel like se
volete vedere altre ricette di slime si
accolla altissimi la lex andrò a farne
un'altra e niente se vi volete rilassare
un po vi lascio con un po di sony questo
stranissimo fantastico
[Musica]